tell us about what this was an
assignment I take it actually was fun it
was early on and I had to I had to keep
getting these assignments so some unwary
magazine said oh yeah go ahead shoot
that and I went to the Golden Gate
Bridge office and said I'm a
photographer and this magazine wants to
do a story on the bridge painters and
they said oh yeah go out and see Joe
he's the foreman he'll fix you up
and so I I show was thought it was
really funny and I was crawling around
the bridge for a couple of weeks and
they were all amuse and after you know
they they saw me running around and a
couple of times they saved me from doing
dangerous things I must say there were
vantage points that I had you know
photography is all about getting your
camera located the proper viewpoint so
that's what what I was always about
that's what made aerials and even
underwater necessary but here for
instance I was underneath the roadbed
which was really the scariest place that
little thing in the center is Alcatraz
and when you're beneath the roadbed
there is a very odd sensation because
you cannot see the usually cannot see
the horizon so you look down and if
there's a breeze you see Whitecaps
moving underneath you and the sensation
is that the bridge is falling over it's
very very that that's that is much
scarier than being up on top being up on
top is achieved by there is in each
tower there is a tiny electric elevator
and it will accommodate two painters and
if they hold their lunch bucket on their
top of their head and it goes fairly
slowly up at the top they've also
discovered that you can get two more
guys on top of the cage if you remember
to stop the elevator and time otherwise
of thoughts are good but the first time
I got up on top I was so excited that I
ran out and started to run down a cable
and well like I said I buddy I think you
better come back here I want to give you
a safety belt and I really appreciated
your concern
[Music]